vous avez su canaliser un moment de
votre vie mais est-ce que vous êtes
confessé dans votre travail quand
j'étais petit
nous avons gardé un bon souvenir pas
terrible aïe aïe aïe je crains pour moi
alors ah bah maintenant je suis plus
grande ça va être un casse bonbons on y
va alors atteint les confessions jamais
quand vous étiez petit vous avez
réellement voulu être religieuse oui je
devais avoir 5 ans j'étais frappé par le
rituel égalité d'humeur
c'est à dire que dans la vie à la maison
c'était plutôt en dents de scie j'aimais
la musique j'aimais l'ordonance voilà
j'aime beaucoup la rigueur quand vous
dites j'ai un maître intérieur de qui
s'agit-il
je viens qu'à partir du moment où on
n'est pas perméable comme une éponge et
où on ne se laisse pas influencer par
tout ce qui nous entoure et qu'on ne vit
pas que par rapport au regard des autres
au jugement des autres cette voie là
s'expriment
vous avez toujours préféré le terme
sensualité et sexualité est un peu anti
sexualité au fond - dont on parle et non
parce que je laisse ça aux rapports des
corps et une dimension
une dimension divine j'ai trop de
respect pour tout individu tout être
humain
à commencer par mois vous considérez que
le corps est un morceau de viande des
quelque chose qui qui se défait qui qui
pourrit et le rapport et la jouissance
rapport d'essence et la jouissance donne
une idée plus précise de l'ex task
simplement un orgasme 1 coûte que comme
disait mon analyste qui laisse pas grand
chose
je lui dis nous sommes autre chose que
de la matière oui croyons dieu le terme
croire est un terme profane ça à voir
avec la crédulité je ne crois que ce que
je vois
j'ai une sensation très exact de quelque
chose de magnifique croyons l'homme
l'esprit mais quand vous dites on vit
seul et au mur seules la solitude n'est
pas une erreur épouvantable c'est c'est
quelque chose d'exaltant parce que la
solitude ne veut pas dire être isolé ne
veut pas dire être séparés des autres
c'est être avec les autres et si je suis
conscient de ma solitude je peux encore
mieux comprendre celle des autres et la
souffrance de ceux qui ne la supporte
pas bien merci morgen